con más de tres millones y medio de
contagios brasil es el segundo país en
el mundo con más casos de ccoo y 19 sin
embargo la propagación del coronavirus
podría estar a punto de desacelerarse
por primera vez desde abril la tasa de
transmisión de kobe 19 se está
desacelerando en brasil según datos del
centro de control de epidemias del
imperial college de londres la tasa de
contagio en brasil fue de 0,98 un número
que indica a cuántas personas puede
contagiar un paciente infectado del
coronavirus los trabajadores de la salud
insisten sin embargo en que la aparente
ralentización no es motivo para suavizar
las medidas preventivas como el uso de
mascarillas y el distanciamiento social
pero es el segundo país de américa
latina en la lista de los más
contagiados a nivel mundial la nación
andina superó el medio millón de casos
positivos por lo que el gobierno
actualmente coordina la compra de 30
millones de dosis de la vacuna contra el
jove 19 con 5 laboratorios extranjeros a
finales de agosto comenzarán los ensayos
clínicos de la vacuna de la universidad
de oxford con voluntarios peruanos
méxico está por detrás de perú en la
lista regional de contagios de un millón
211 mil 552 pruebas aplicadas para
detectar el coronavirus el 45% han
tenido un resultado positivo uno de los
golpes más duros para méxico así como
para el resto de países ha sido en su
economía el trabajo informal es elevado
y son estas personas las que más han
sufrido en los últimos meses
bajar la venta
cerrar colombia le sigue a mexico en la
lista bogotá donde está el foco de la
infección ha tenido que implementar
varias cuarentenas obligatorias por
localidades lo que ha detenido los
contagios levemente